This lesson does not provide details on how to do analytics.
Rather we will explore
the specialized infrastructures and tools that support research on,
an exploration of, health data at scale.
Generally this involves aggregating
at least the clinical part of that data from a large number of
digital health records.This introduces
the interoperability issues we've been discussing throughout the course.
Advanced analysis of these big health data sets offers the promise of more precise,
personalized care and the use of
predictive tools to anticipate and treat clinical problems much
earlier than was possible in the past.This
analysis must overcome many typical problems and limitations of the HR data.
Despite the challenges we are clearly heading into a new era of medicine and health care.
This lesson provides you with at least a feel for what that might be like.